Over the past six years, the U.S. Food and Drug Administration has approved dozens of apps designed to treat health problems, including mental health issues such as post-traumatic stress disorder, chronic insomnia, and substance use disorders. As our nation struggles with a shortage of mental health providers, advocates say that these apps, called digital therapeutics, could provide an important tool to get mental health treatment to people who might not otherwise be able to access it. But many questions remain about how these treatments will be regulated, prescribed, paid for, and accessed. Today we're going to explore some of those questions. What are digital therapeutics? How do they work? How do they differ from the hundreds of other unregulated mental health and wellness apps in app stores? What kinds of mental health conditions can they treat? Who regulates digital therapeutics?
在过去六年里，美国食品药品监督管理局已经批准了数十款旨在治疗健康问题的应用程序，其中包括创伤后应激障碍、慢性失眠和物质使用障碍等心理健康问题。正当我国努力应对心理健康服务人员短缺的问题时，倡导者表示，这些被称为数字疗法的应用程序可以提供一个重要的工具，将心理健康治疗带给那些本来无法获得治疗的人。然而，关于这些治疗将如何受到监管、开具处方、支付费用以及获取使用，仍有许多问题亟待解答。今天我们将探讨其中一些问题。什么是数字疗法？它们是如何运作的？它们与应用商店中成百上千种未经监管的其他心理健康与保健应用程序有何不同？它们可以治疗哪些类型的心理健康状况？谁来监管数字疗法？
Who prescribes them and who pays for them? How strong is the evidence that they work? and what role might they play in expanding access to mental health care? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Vale Wright, a clinical psychologist and the Senior Director of Healthcare Innovation at the American Psychological Association.
谁来开具处方，谁来支付费用？它们有效的证据有多充分？它们在扩大心理健康服务获取方面可能扮演什么角色？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是韦尔·赖特博士（Dr. Vale Wright），她是一名临床心理学家，也是美国心理学协会医疗保健创新高级主任。
In that role, she focuses on developing strategies to leverage technical technology, and data to address issues within health care, including improving access to care, measuring care, and optimizing treatment delivery. She's also a leading spokesperson for APA and has been interviewed by TV, radio, print, and online media, including The Washington Post, the New York Times, NPR, and many more on topics including stress, trauma, telehealth, and technology. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Wright. Thanks, Kim. I'm excited to be here. And because we've known each other for years, I'm going to call you Veil.
在该职位上，她专注于制定战略，利用技术和数据来解决医疗保健领域的问题，包括改善获取护理的途径、衡量护理质量以及优化治疗传递。她也是美国心理学协会的主要发言人，曾接受过电视、广播、平面和网络媒体的采访，包括《华盛顿邮报》、《纽约时报》、全国公共广播电台（NPR）等众多媒体，探讨的主题涵盖压力、创伤、远程医疗和技术。非常感谢您今天能来，赖特博士。谢谢你，金。我很高兴能来到这里。而且因为我们认识多年了，我还是叫你韦尔吧。
I appreciate that. Let's start with an overview of what we mean when we refer to digital therapeutics. What are digital therapeutics and what's the difference between them and the many other mental health and wellness apps that anyone might come across in app stores like Apple or Google Play? Yeah, digital therapeutics are software programs that you can access on your phone, your tablet, your computer, and they deliver evidence-based. and validated psychological treatments to treat things like depression or anxiety and a variety of different mental health disorders. I think where it gets confusing is that these are not direct-to-consumer apps that you can download off the app store of your choice. Those apps like Calm or Headspace are designed to teach coping skills, such as mindfulness meditation or stress management, but they don't treat disorders like depression or anxiety.
我很乐意。让我们先概述一下我们所说的“数字疗法”是什么意思。什么是数字疗法？它与任何人可能会在苹果或谷歌应用商店等平台上下载的众多其他心理健康与健康应用程序有什么区别？是的，数字疗法是通过手机、平板电脑或电脑访问的软件程序，它们提供基于证据且经过验证的心理治疗，用于治疗抑郁症、焦虑症以及各种不同的心理健康障碍。我认为容易混淆的地方在于，这些并不是你可以从所选的应用商店下载的直接面向消费者的应用程序。像 Calm 或 Headspace 这样的应用程序旨在教授应对技巧，例如正念冥想或压力管理，但它们并不治疗抑郁症或焦虑症等障碍。
And that's what digital therapeutics are really designed to do, to treat. treat disorders. So how do digital therapeutics work? Are they just automated versions of the type of therapies that someone might engage in with a psychologist or another mental health provider? Are they actually artificial intelligence versions of an actual psychotherapist, or do they work differently? So digital therapeutics have taken well-established treatments, such as cognitive behavioral therapy or CBT, and digitize them. And honestly, this constant isn't new. Online versions of CBT have existed for a while. But what is new is the sophistication of the technology, like you just mentioned. So they use AI, including machine learning and natural language processing,
这正是数字疗法真正旨在做的事情——治疗各种障碍。那么，数字疗法是如何运作的呢？它们只是人们与心理学家或其他心理健康服务提供者进行的那类疗法的自动化版本吗？它们实际上是真正的心理治疗师的人工智能版本，还是其运作方式有所不同？数字疗法采用了一直以来行之有效的治疗方法，例如认知行为疗法（CBT），并将其数字化。说实话，这个概念并不是新事物。CBT 的在线版本已经存在了一段时间。但新的是技术的复杂性，正如你刚才提到的。因此，它们使用人工智能，包括机器学习和自然语言处理，
to personalize the treatment to the patient. So if I can give an example, let's say you are somebody who's interested in using CBT for insomnia. And your chronic insomnia issue is that you have problems falling asleep, but not necessarily staying asleep or waking up too early. And so these AI-driven devices can actually personalize the treatment and the interventions that they offer you based on what it is that you're presenting. So they would help you with how to fall asleep, but wouldn't necessarily give you skills on how to stay to sleep because that's not what you need. So that's really what makes them unique. What other mental health conditions have digital therapeutics been approved to treat up until now? So there have been a few that have gone through the formal FDA clearance process for mental health disorders like substance use, anxiety.
来为患者定制治疗方案。举个例子，假设你是一个有兴趣使用认知行为疗法（CBT）来治疗失眠的人。你长期的失眠问题是入睡困难，而不一定是维持睡眠或醒得太早。因此，这些人工智能驱动的设备实际上可以根据你所呈现的症状，个性化地为你提供治疗和干预措施。所以它们会帮助你解决如何入睡的问题，但不一定会教你如何保持睡眠的技巧，因为那不是你所需要的。这正是它们真正独特的地方。在此之前，数字疗法已被批准治疗哪些其他心理健康状况？所以，有一些已经通过了美国食品药品监督管理局（FDA）的正式审批程序，用于治疗物质使用、焦虑、
and trauma, ADHD, and you're also seeing them expand into more physical health conditions like irritable bowel syndrome and pain disorders. So actual psychotherapy can help with irritable bowel disorders, for example. I mean, that strikes me as almost miraculous. Yeah, there are a lot of ways in which predominantly CBT, but other types of psychological interventions like biofeedback, can actually address physical health conditions instead of using traditional pharmaceuticals, which may have a lot of negative side effects. So if we can find that, you know, psychological interventions are just as effective, if not more effective,
创伤、注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADHD），而且你还会发现它们正在扩展到更多身体健康状况，如肠易激综合征和疼痛障碍。因此，实际的心理治疗可以帮助解决肠易激综合征等问题。我的意思是，这让我觉得简直是个奇迹。是的，在很多情况下，主要是认知行为疗法（CBT），以及生物反馈等其他类型的心理健康干预措施，实际上都可以用来解决身体健康问题，而无需使用可能具有许多负面副作用的传统药物。因此，如果我们发现，你知道的，心理干预同样有效，甚至更有效，
then this is another really great way to get these types of interventions into the hands of the patients that need them. How strong is the evidence that they work and how do they compare to traditional in-person therapy or even teletherapy? Yeah, we've seen really robust findings from randomized control trials, that these products, digital therapeutics, are effective and appear to be as effective as in-person therapy. And we've even seen some studies that suggest that digital therapeutists can deliver a treatment intervention in fewer sessions than in-person therapy. So there are potential cost benefits there as well as freeing up time for providers to be able to see more patients. But all that said, providers play a really important role in the use of digital therapeutic. So it's not going to replace them in any way, but instead, providers help determine whether
那么这又是一个将这些类型的干预措施交到真正需要的患者手中的绝佳途径。它们有效的证据有多强？它们与传统的面对面治疗甚至远程治疗相比如何？是的，我们从随机对照试验中看到了非常强有力的研究结果，证明这些产品——数字疗法——是有效的，并且其效果似乎与面对面治疗不相上下。我们甚至看到一些研究表明，数字疗法可以用比面对面治疗更少的疗程来提供治疗干预。因此，这不仅在成本上有潜在益处，还能腾出时间让服务提供者能够诊治更多的患者。话虽如此，服务提供者在使用数字疗法方面发挥着非常重要的作用。因此，它不会以任何方式取代他们，相反，服务提供者帮助确定
a digital therapeutic is appropriate for a patient. They help them set it up and learn how to use it. And then providers need to monitor the treatment over time to make sure the outcomes are what we hope they are, that utilization is robust so that we can be sure that these things are working the way they're supposed to in that a patient doesn't actually need a higher level of care because they're in crisis. And in fact, a recent meta-analysis came out that showed that when these types of digital mental health interventions have provider involvement, they're actually more effective. So we think it's a pretty critical component.
数字疗法是否适合某个患者。他们帮助患者进行设置并学习如何使用它。然后，服务提供者需要随着时间的推移对治疗进行监测，以确保治疗结果符合我们的预期，确保使用率足够高，从而让我们确信这些东西正按预期发挥作用，并且患者没有因为处于危机之中而实际需要更高水平的护理。事实上，最近发布的一项元分析显示，当这些类型的数字心理健康干预措施有服务提供者参与时，它们实际上会更加有效。因此，我们认为这是一个相当关键的组成部分。
Now, what are they like? I mean, if I were to access one of these digital therapeutics, what would I be hearing when I turned on my phone, put in my earbuds and, you know, turned it on? So the technology differs, depending on the actual therapeutics. Some are a bit more robust than others. but many have some sort of chat bot type feature or an avatar that would interact with you in real time and would again tailor the treatment based on what your responses are to various prompts. And these treatment interventions and the scripts that the chatbot uses, they've been designed by experts in the field.
那么，它们是什么样的呢？我的意思是，如果我要使用这些数字疗法之一，当我打开手机、戴上耳机并，你知道的，启动它时，我会听到什么？技术因实际的疗法而异。有些比其他的更强大一些。但许多疗法都有某种聊天机器人功能或头像，可以与你实时互动，并会根据你对各种提示的反应再次定制治疗方案。这些治疗干预措施以及聊天机器人使用的脚本都是由该领域的专家设计的。
So we know that they're based on the best evidenced psychological treatments that exist. And then you would use them on a weekly basis, maybe, you know, every five days or so as you go through the treatment protocol kind of at your own pace. But ideally, you know, often enough that you're seeing the real benefits. But you have that convenience of doing it from your own home as opposed to having to go into a more traditional sort of therapy office on a weekly basis. And then when the therapist you're working with is interacting with you, I assume that he or she is getting some kind of data from the app and then what? I mean, is there some interpretation and modification as you go along? Yeah, absolutely.
因此我们知道，它们是基于现有的最佳循证心理治疗。然后你可能会以每周一次的频率使用它们，比如，你知道的，每五天左右一次，以你自己的节奏经历治疗方案。但理想情况下，你知道的，频率要足够高，这样你才能看到真正的益处。不过，你拥有在自己家中进行操作的便利性，而不必每周前往更传统的治疗办公室。然后，当你合作的治疗师与你互动时，我假设他或她会从应用程序中获得一些数据，然后呢？我的意思是，在你进行的过程中，是否存在某种解释和修改？是的，绝对会的。
Again, it will depend a little bit. It might differ a bit depending on the provider. But ideally, the provider is, you know, tracking the outcome data that's coming through the device. So, you know, on a weekly basis, the patient may take a brief survey, just checking to see how their symptoms are. And if they're improving, there are usually, you know, messaging features so the provider can provide asynchronous messages to the patient to let them know how they're doing. Or you can schedule, you know, maybe every four weeks you schedule a brief phone call to just check in, see how it's going, make sure it's still working, and you still have that more kind of personal face-to-face or, you know, on the telephone kind of touch. So I think there's a variety of different ways that the patient still feels connected to the provider, even though they're receiving an evidence-based treatment in their own home. What's the regulatory process for approving these?
再次说明，这会略有不同。根据服务提供者的不同，可能会有一些差异。但理想情况下，服务提供者正在，你知道的，追踪通过设备传来的结果数据。所以，你知道的，每周一次，患者可能会做一个简短的调查，只是检查一下他们的症状如何。如果他们正在改善，通常会有，你知道的，消息功能，以便服务提供者可以向患者提供异步消息，让他们知道自己情况如何。或者你可以安排，你知道的，也许每四周安排一次简短的电话沟通，只是为了解情况，看看进展如何，确保它仍然有效，并且你仍然拥有那种更具个人色彩的面对面的，或者，你知道的，通过电话的接触。因此，我认为有各种不同的方式让患者仍然觉得自己与服务提供者保持着联系，尽管他们是在自己家里接受基于证据的治疗。批准这些疗法的监管程序是什么？
I mentioned earlier that some have been cleared by the FDA. Does the FDA regulate them in the same way that they regulate prescription drugs or medical devices? Currently, the process is very similar. So the FDA is tasked with regulating the space because these devices make claims that they diagnose, treat, or cure a medical disorder. And those words are really critical. You know, diagnose, treat, or cure. That's the part that makes it fall under the FDA. And the FDA primarily focuses on two things.
我刚才提到有些已经获得了美国食品药品监督管理局（FDA）的批准。FDA 对它们的监管方式是否与对处方药或医疗设备的监管方式相同？目前，这个过程非常相似。因此，FDA 的任务是监管这个领域，因为这些设备声称它们可以诊断、治疗或治愈某种医疗障碍。这些词非常关键。你知道的，诊断、治疗或治愈。这正是让它落入 FDA 管辖范围的部分。FDA 主要关注两件事。
The first is efficacy. So device makers need to demonstrate via randomized control trials and other types of research that their product actually works. And secondly, they focus on safety. And so that's how we get to the regulatory process in that the FDA has two pathways. One is they can determine that a device is relatively safe, safe enough that you don't need a provider involved. And so they distribute those over the counter. Or you can have devices that do require a lot of. of provider involvement. And then these devices need to be prescribed or ordered by an appropriate,
首先是疗效。因此，设备制造商需要通过随机对照试验和其他类型的研究来证明他们的产品确实有效。其次，他们关注安全性。这就是我们如何进入监管程序的，因为 FDA 有两条途径。一条途径是他们可以确定某种设备相对安全，安全到不需要服务提供者参与。因此他们将这些设备作为非处方药分发。或者你也可以拥有确实需要大量服务提供者参与的设备。然后，这些设备需要由适当的，
you know, medical provider. So in the case of mental health digital therapeutics, that could be a psychologist, a social worker, or it could be a primary care physician or another specialty type doctor. So the prescription authority sounds like it's pretty broad at this point. You don't need an MD, for example, as you might with drugs or in the case of psychologists who provide, they have to go to school and get extra certification. Doesn't sound like that's the case here. There's a lot of confusion, I would argue, around the regulatory space because the FDA only has two pathways. And one of those pathways is deemed, quote unquote, prescription. And so we all, I think,
你知道的，医疗服务提供者开具处方或订购。因此，在心理健康数字疗法的情况下，这可能是心理学家、社会工作者，或者可能是基层医疗医生或其他专科医生。所以处方权听起来在目前相当广泛。例如，你不需要像药品那样必须具备医学博士（MD）身份，或者像提供治疗的心理学家那样必须去学校获得额外认证。听起来这里并非如此。我想说，围绕监管领域存在很多混乱，因为 FDA 只有两条途径。其中一条途径被认为，引号中的“处方”。因此我认为我们所有人，
just immediately go to this idea of it's the same as prescribing pharmaceuticals. We don't think that that is the case. When the FDA says prescribe or order a software, what they're really wanting is for the device maker to determine in their labeling who is appropriate to prescribe or order. And because these types of mental health digital therapeutics use psychological treatments that are within the scope of practice of a variety of different providers like psychologists, you know, as long as the device maker includes them in the label, we believe that psychologists are able to prescribe and or order these products when appropriate with their patients. Are digital therapeutics covered by insurance right now?
都会立刻得出这样的想法：这与开具药物处方是一样的。我们认为并非如此。当 FDA 说“为软件开具处方或订购软件”时，他们真正希望的是设备制造商在其标签中确定谁适合开具处方或订购。而且由于这些类型的心理健康数字疗法使用了在各种不同服务提供者（如心理学家）执业范围内的心理治疗，你知道的，只要设备制造商将其纳入标签中，我们相信心理学家能够在适当时与患者一起开具和/或订购这些产品。目前保险是否涵盖数字疗法？
And if not, what's the outlook for that? Currently, there's no universal way for reimbursing digital therapeutics within our traditional healthcare system. And so, you know, you have kind of a variety of different ways that individuals might access these products. One is you have certain systems like the VA or Kaiser Permanente who have incorporated digital mental health within their offerings to their patients within their various systems. In other sorts of cases, you might have these device companies having made contracts with different employers so that if you're an employee of that company, you can access the product through your benefit portal.
如果没有，前景如何？目前，在我们的传统医疗保健系统中，还没有一种通用的方式来报销数字疗法。因此，你知道的，个人可能会通过各种不同的方式来获取这些产品。其中一种是，你拥有某些系统，比如退伍军人事务部（VA）或凯萨医疗（Kaiser Permanente），他们在其各种系统的患者服务中纳入了数字心理健康服务。在其他类型的情况下，你可能会看到这些设备公司与不同的雇主签订了合同，因此如果你是该公司的员工，你可以通过你的福利门户网站访问该产品。
And so I think ideally we want to get to a place where we have broader access because we have more traditional reimbursement, but we're just not quite there yet. In the long term, how do you think digital therapeutics will fit into the landscape of how people access mental health treatment? Will they replace in-person therapy, do you think, at some point? I don't think that they'll replace in-person therapy. I think there's always going to be the need for high-touch levels of care from person to person on a weekly sort of 45-minute psychotherapy basis. But I also think that to address the mental health crisis, we need to be thinking more innovatively, and we need to break away from the status quo of how we've always done things. And I think digital therapeutics can be an important tool for providers. to address access and efficiency and care.
因此我认为，理想情况下，我们希望达到一个拥有更广泛获取途径的阶段，因为我们有了更传统的报销方式，但我们目前还没有完全做到这一点。从长远来看，你认为数字疗法将如何融入人们获取心理健康治疗的格局中？你认为它们在某个时候会取代面对面治疗吗？我不认为它们会取代面对面治疗。我认为总是需要人与人之间高接触水平的护理，比如每周进行45分钟左右的心理治疗。但我也认为，为了应对心理健康危机，我们需要进行更多创新性思考，并且我们需要打破我们一贯做事方式的现状。并且我认为数字疗法可以成为服务提供者的一项重要工具，
And so I think it's going to look a few different ways. One example would be to address wait lists. So we know that wait lists are incredibly long right now. So maybe you're a parent and your child has recently been diagnosed with ADHD. You want them to have medication and psychotherapy. But the psychotherapy wait list is six months. Could you use a digital therapeutic design for ADHD in that meantime while you're waiting on that wait list? So that's one example.
以解决获取途径和护理效率的问题。因此我认为它会有几种不同的面貌。一个例子是解决等待名单问题。我们知道现在等待名单长得不可思议。所以也许你是一位父母，你的孩子最近被诊断出患有注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADHD）。你希望他们服药并接受心理治疗。但心理治疗的等待名单是六个月。在你等待的那段期间，你可以使用为 ADHD 设计的数字疗法吗？这就是一个例子。
Another might be, you know, individuals living in rural areas that don't have a lot of access to care. You know, you see your primary care physician, you're reporting chronic insomnia. You don't want to take medications for a variety of reasons, including addiction and side effects. But there isn't any provider that does CBT for insomnia in your area. So could you use a digital therapeutic design for that to address that space? And my last example will just be, I think there's a lot of room to incorporate patient preference. within our health care systems. So the example I always give is, you know,
另一个例子可能是，你知道的，生活在偏远地区、没有太多途径获得护理的个人。你看过基层医疗医生，你报告说有慢性失眠。由于各种原因（包括成瘾和副作用），你不想服药。但在你的地区没有任何提供失眠认知行为疗法（CBT-I）的服务提供者。那么你可以使用为此设计的数字疗法来解决这个空白吗？我的最后一个例子是，我认为在我们的医疗系统中，有很多空间可以纳入患者的偏好。所以我总是举的例子是，你知道的，
maybe you have somebody who is been diagnosed with cancer and they're receiving weekly, you know, oncology visits to treat it, but they have anxiety on top of it, which wouldn't be sat surprising, but let's say they don't want to come back on a weekly basis in addition to that cancer treatment just to see another therapist. Could you use a digital therapeutic that they could take home with them that a provider monitors, you know, from afar,
也许你有一个被诊断患有癌症的人，他们每周接受肿瘤科门诊治疗，但除此之外他们还有焦虑症，这并不令人惊讶，但假设除了癌症治疗之外，他们不想每周回来一次仅仅为了去看另一个治疗师。你可以使用他们可以带回家的数字疗法，由服务提供者，你知道的，从远处进行监测，
in order to really address the mental health needs and the physical health needs of people in this country. So I think there's a lot of really interesting opportunities, as long as we can address the barriers to scalability and get these into the hands of the people that need them. How aware is the average provider of the existence of digital therapeutics in order to prescribe them? I mean, as a consumer, I wouldn't really be able to just go someplace and find them, right? I mean, they're not in the app store. So if my psychologist doesn't know about these digital therapeutics, how do I get that information? I think that lack of knowledge about this space is the number one barrier to getting broader access to care. I think that, you know, psychologists as well as other providers just aren't that aware of these new products, even though we've seen a surge in them since the start of the pandemic.
以便真正满足这个国家人民的心理健康需求和身体健康需求。因此，我认为这里有许多非常有趣的机会，只要我们能够解决可扩展性的障碍，并将这些产品交到真正需要它们的人手中。普通服务提供者对数字疗法的存在了解多少，以便为患者开具处方？我的意思是，作为消费者，我实际上无法直接去某处找到它们，对吧？我的意思是，它们不在应用商店里。所以如果我的心理学家不知道这些数字疗法，我该如何获取这些信息？我认为缺乏对这个领域的了解是获得更广泛护理获取途径的首要障碍。我认为，你知道的，心理学家以及其他服务提供者对这些新产品并不是那么了解，尽管自从大流行开始以来，我们已经看到它们激增。
I think because they haven't been incorporated into traditional health care, we're just not seeing. seeing as much usage as certainly we would like to see. So, you know, as part of what we're doing, including this podcast, is we're really trying to get education out to both consumers but also providers, that these are new opportunities, new tools, and to seek them out. So I think that, you know, APA is working really hard to address the regulatory barriers and the reimbursement barriers. And ideally, when we solve both of those, our next step is going to have to be how do we help providers know how to use these in their practice? How do they incorporate them into their workflow in a way that is assistive and not, you know, just another administrative burden? So I think there's a lot of work to be done. But I'm excited that APA is at the forefront of doing a lot of this work.
我认为因为它们尚未被纳入传统的医疗保健中，所以我们并没有看到。看到像我们当然希望看到的那么多使用量。因此，你知道的，作为我们正在做的事情的一部分，包括这个播客，我们真的在努力向消费者和提供者普及教育，即这些是新的机会、新的工具，并去寻找它们。因此我认为，APA 正在非常努力地解决监管障碍和报销障碍。理想情况下，当我们解决这两者之后，我们的下一步将不得不思考：我们如何帮助提供者了解如何在其实践中使用这些？他们如何以一种具有辅助性而不是，你知道的，仅仅是增加另一个行政负担的方式将它们融入工作流程中？因此，我认为还有很多工作要做。但我很高兴 APA 处于开展其中许多工作的前沿。
Are the companies that create these digital therapeutics, are they using the same marketing techniques that, say, the pharmaceutical industry uses where there are. actual sales reps who go and visit doctors? I don't think that most of the companies are at that space yet. I think that they are still, you know, trying to determine what regulatory path they want to work, go down. How can they continue to get the research that they need in order to demonstrate the efficacy of their products? And so, and how do we, how do they get them paid for? I do see them likely moving in that path in the future, although I would also argue that the more that we equate traditional therapeutics to the pharmaceutical company, the more confusion I think we end up having. So I think it's important to really consider these as therapy tools akin to, you know, traditional psychotherapy models that we're accustomed to. And so we need to pay for them similarly.
创建这些数字疗法的公司，是否在使用与比如说制药行业相同的营销技术，即有实际的销售代表去拜访医生？我认为大多数公司还没有达到那个阶段。我认为他们仍然，你知道的，在试图确定他们想要走哪条监管道路。他们如何才能继续获得他们所需的研究，以证明其产品的疗效？因此，还有，我们如何，他们如何为这些产品获得报销？我确实看到他们将来可能会朝着那个方向发展，尽管我也要说，我们将传统疗法与制药公司等同得越多，我认为最终导致的混乱就越多。因此，我认为重要的是真正将这些视为类似于，你知道的，我们习惯的传统心理治疗模式的治疗工具。因此我们需要以类似的方式为它们付费，
and we need to just be talking about them in a very similar manner. But in the meantime, let's say that I'm interested in using one of these digital therapeutics, what is the average cost if I'm going to have to pay out of my pocket because my insurance doesn't cover it? What should I expect to pay? Yeah, the cost really varies for companies that are charging. You know, it can be anywhere from $500 to $1,500 for the device for the software itself. And generally, it also includes some sort of monthly. kind of subscription cost.
并且我们需要以非常类似的方式来谈论它们。但在那之前，假设我有兴趣使用这些数字疗法之一，如果因为我的保险不报销而必须自掏腰包，平均费用是多少？我应该预期支付多少钱？是的，收费公司的费用确实差异很大。你知道的，软件设备本身的费用可能在 500 到 1500 美元之间。通常，它还包括某种每月的，
Because a lot of these companies are just trying to get their products out to the people, some of them actually give them away from free at this point. So, you know, I think there's a really wide variety on the business models and the processes and the distribution model. And again, that variety causes a lot of challenges. If we had a bit more universality, I think we will achieve better scalability and actual access to these products. Let's talk a little more broadly about mental health apps, including the ones that are not digital therapeutics, are not prescribed, but anyone can access in an app store.
某种订阅费用。因为其中许多公司只是试图将他们的产品推向人们，所以在这一点上，其中一些公司实际上是免费赠送的。因此，你知道的，我认为商业模式、流程和分销模式存在着非常广泛的差异。再次强调，这种差异带来了许多挑战。如果我们能有更多的普遍性，我认为我们将实现更好的可扩展性和对这些产品的实际获取。让我们更广泛地谈谈心理健康应用程序，包括那些不是数字疗法、没有处方、但任何人都能在应用商店中访问的应用程序。
How can consumers evaluate these apps? Honestly, it is not easy. You really have to do the research, and you need to go to the company's website and search for published research studies that show that the products are effective. You need to look to see if they have mental health professionals and experts, either working for the company, helping to design the app and or that serve on different advisory committees like a scientific advisory committee. These are not often things you're going to find on the app store itself. So you really do have to kind of do your own research. And just as importantly, you need to seek out what their
消费者如何评估这些应用程序？说实话，这并不容易。你真的必须进行研究，你需要访问公司的网站并搜索已发布的科学研究，以证明这些产品是有效的。你需要查看他们是否有心理健康专业人员和专家，要么为公司工作、协助设计应用程序，和/或在不同的咨询委员会（如科学咨询委员会）中任职。这些通常不是你在应用商店本身就能找到的东西。所以你确实必须进行自己的研究。同样重要的是，你需要查明他们的
Because we've had some really high profile cases lately of different online or app companies, selling your personal information to advertisers. And so obviously, that's not something you want. But it also puts you at risk for identity theft and other types of challenges. So it's important to do your due diligence, to do your homework, to not just look at the rating on the app store and use that as your way to determine and whether or not this is a good tool for you. So are there different controls then around digital therapeutics that are FDA-approved?
因为我们最近有一些备受瞩目的案例，涉及不同的在线或应用程序公司将你的个人信息出售给广告商。所以很显然，这不是你想要的。但这也会让你面临身份盗窃和其他类型挑战的风险。因此，进行尽职调查、做好功课非常重要，不能仅仅看应用商店里的评分，并以此作为确定这是否是适合你的好工具的方法。那么，获得 FDA 批准的数字疗法周围是否有不同的控制措施？
Would they be covered by HIPAA, which makes your information confidential? Absolutely. That's a really, really important point. So because digital therapeutics, you know, again, purport to diagnose, treat or cure a mental disorder, they are bound by certain privacy laws like HIPAA. And so they have to demonstrate to the FDA and to their consumers and providers that they are going the extra mile to protect personal health information. Apps from the app store have no obligation to do that. They are not bound by HIPAA. And so they can take your personal health information and kind of do whatever they want with it.
它们是否会受到《健康保险流通与责任法案》（HIPAA）的保护，从而使你的信息保密？绝对会。这是一个非常非常重要的点。因此，由于数字疗法，你知道的，再次宣称能够诊断、治疗或治愈心理障碍，它们受到某些隐私法（如 HIPAA）的约束。因此，它们必须向 FDA、消费者和提供者证明，它们正在加倍努力保护个人健康信息。来自应用商店的应用程序没有义务这样做。它们不受 HIPAA 的约束。因此它们可以拿走你的个人健康信息，并随心所欲地处理它。
There isn't any regulatory oversight of the directed consumer, the wellness apps, the lifestyle apps. And so that's something also to keep in mind. So there's nobody really making determinations whether those types of apps are effective or whether they are safe. So what's APA's role in the promulgation of digital apps? Is APA considering approving apps or giving a seal of like a good housekeeping seal of approval for apps? Is there any role that you are playing as you're reviewing some of these therapeutics right now? So in the wellness and lifestyle app space, you know, our role has really been to help inform consumers on what to look for if they're looking to use one of those products. And we've also have historically had a column within our office called Let's Get Technical.
对直接面向消费者的、健康类应用程序、生活方式应用程序没有任何监管监督。因此这也是需要牢记的一点。所以没有人真正在判断这些类型的应用程序是否有效，或者它们是否安全。那么 APA 在数字应用程序的推广中扮演什么角色？APA 是否考虑批准应用程序，或者为应用程序提供某种类似于“美好家园”式的优质认证？在你目前审查其中一些疗法时，你是否在扮演任何角色？所以在健康和生活方式应用程序领域，你知道的，我们的角色实际上一直是帮助消费者了解在寻求使用其中一种产品时应该寻找什么。并且我们在我们的办公室里历来都有一个名为“让我们技术化”（Let's Get Technical）的专栏。
That's reviewed different apps in different spaces. We also often point individuals to other groups that have engaged in sort of evaluation of these apps. But it's a really challenging resource-intensive space. to be because these apps can change all the time. And so once you reviewed it and maybe you've given it your seal of approval, they could turn around and change their
该专栏审查了不同领域的不同应用程序。我们也经常向个人指出其他参与了此类应用程序评估的群体。但这是一个极具挑战性、资源密集型的领域。因为这些应用程序随时可能更改。因此，一旦你对其进行了审查并可能给予了优质认证，它们可能会转过身来改变它们的
When it comes to digital therapeutics, we've really been working closely with a variety of different device companies to help them navigate this regulatory reimbursement space. Because I think if we can all get on the same page and work together, then we're much more likely to have a big impact on solving this mental health crisis. Because again, these digital therapeutics, they use what we already know works to reach more and more people to help them get the psychological treatment that they need. And so I think, you know, that's really where we spent a lot of our focus is in that space because we think it can have the biggest impact. So to wrap up, what would you say are the biggest challenges that the field of digital
当谈到数字疗法时，我们一直在与各种不同的设备公司密切合作，帮助他们驾驭这个监管报销领域。因为我认为如果我们能达成共识并共同努力，那么我们更有可能对解决这场心理健康危机产生重大影响。因为再次强调，这些数字疗法利用了我们已经知道有效的方法，以接触越来越多的人，帮助他们获得所需的心理治疗。因此我认为，你知道的，这确实是我们投入大量精力的领域，因为我们认为它能产生最大的影响。那么总结一下，你认为数字疗法领域目前面临的最大挑战是什么？
therapeutics faces right now? I think the biggest challenge is lack of understanding of what these are and what they aren't. I think they often get conflated with wellness apps, which, again, might have a role in being helpful, but we know that they're not used very often. They're downloaded once and then sort of abandoned. And so helping people really understand how digital therapeutics are different, how they're meant to provide a different service, and how we have a higher expectation in terms of they're being able to demonstrate effectiveness and safety.
我认为最大的挑战是缺乏对这些是什么以及它们不是什么的理解。我认为它们经常与健康应用程序混淆，而健康应用程序，再次强调，可能在提供帮助方面有一点作用，但我们知道它们并不经常被使用。它们被下载一次然后就被抛弃了。因此，帮助人们真正理解数字疗法有何不同，它们旨在提供不同的服务，以及我们在它们能够证明有效性和安全性方面有更高的期望。
I think if we can get people to really understand that, then we can make better inroads on the barriers around regulation and around reimbursement. People just don't understand what they are. And when we don't understand what something is, we get hesitant. And that's what we're really seeing right now. We're seeing a lack of urgency by policymakers on moving forward and really figuring out solutions to incorporate these into health care. But we've got to do it.
我认为如果我们能让人们真正理解这一点，那么我们就能在围绕监管和报销的障碍上取得更好的突破。人们只是不明白它们是什么。当我们不理解某事是什么时，我们就会犹豫不决。这正是我们目前所看到的。我们看到政策制定者在推进并真正找出将这些纳入医疗保健的解决方案方面缺乏紧迫感。但我们必须这样做。
We've got to think creatively and innovatively to address them into health crisis. We can't just keep doing the same old thing and expect people to get better. Well, Vail, I want to thank you for joining me today. I think the work you're doing is really inspiring and important. And I wish you a great deal of luck and success.
我们必须进行创造性和创新性的思考，以应对医疗危机。我们不能总是墨守成规，却期望人们好转。好的，韦尔，我要感谢你今天加入我。我认为你正在做的工作真的非常鼓舞人心且重要。我祝你一切顺利，取得巨大成功。
Thanks, Kim. It was great talking with you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
谢谢你，金。与你交谈很愉快。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 上找到《心理学谈话》过往的节目，也可以在 Apple、Stitcher、YouTube 或任何你获取喜爱播客的地方收听。如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以给我们发电子邮件：speakingofpsychology@apa.org。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。感谢收听，我是来自美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。